We need to make this program read data from a file and compute the largest one.
We make a file object for the file with name input.text. With that file object
we construct a scanner. And now the rest is exactly like what we had before,
because reading from a scanner that is attached to a file Is no different than
using a scanner that's attached to the console. So here, here, and here we call
next double, and has next double in the usual way. When you run this program,
it'll tell you that it found, as its largest value, a value that is very large.
Let's have a peek at the input file. That file has a lot of numbers in it that
seem kind of meaningless. You'll see in the next exercise with Sara where they
come from.